imaginemos que nos dan un número
complejo zeta ceta que es igual a nose
menos tres menos tres más dos
entonces comencemos por visualizar dónde
está este número complejo z en el plano
vamos a poner por aquí nuestro eje
imaginario
y está nuestro eje imaginario y vamos a
poner también nuestro eje real
es real más o menos algo así ok entonces
nuestro número complejo tiene parte real
-3 así que 12
3 aquí estaría mi parte real en menos 3
y tiene parte imaginaria dos así que 12
2 y mi número complejo z nuestro número
complejo z estaría justo
y dónde está línea de la parte real -3
intersecta a esta línea de la parte
imaginaria todo entonces estaría más o
menos por aquí aquí está zeta
de qué otro modo además de quedando la
parte real y la parte imaginaria de qué
otro modo puede especificar la ubicación
de este número complejo z por ejemplo
pensemos puedo especificar lo dando una
magnitud y una dirección pues vamos a
imaginar que conocemos la distancia que
hay entre z y el origen esta magnitud
que voy a llamar r
y no me basta con especificar la
magnitud la distancia entre z y el
origen también tengo que dar la
dirección así que necesito este ángulo
de aquí este ángulo teta medido en
radiales que se forma a partir del eje
real positivo y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es tratar de relacionar r y
theta con menos 3 y 2 y los invito a
pausar el vídeo detenerlo en este
momento y tratar de encontrar si les doy
este número complejo menos tres más dos
y en la forma rectangular cómo puedo
obtener r y theta a partir de menos 3 y
de 2
la familia que ya lo hicieron y vamos a
empezar recordando la definición de las
funciones trigonométricas a partir del
círculo unitario déjenme dibujo aquí un
círculo unitario
en el círculo unitario más o menos algo
así
y vamos a recordar cuáles son las
coordenadas de este punto que está aquí
de la intersección de esta línea azul
con el círculo unitario pues por
definición si este ángulo mide te está
entonces la coordenada x de este punto
va a ser con seno de teta
y la coordenada ye por definición de las
funciones trigonométricas en el círculo
unitario va a ser seno de teta
muy bien pero eso es cuando este radio
esta magnitud vale 1 en este caso tengo
una magnitud de r en la dirección de
teta así que podemos pensar que todo
está haciendo escalado por un factor de
r
por lo tanto
esta magnitud esta instancia de z acá no
va a ser consciente está va a ser r
veces coseno etc y yo sé que eso vale
menos 3 así que menos 3 tiene que ser
igual a r por el coste no de teta del
mismo modo este esta magnitud de aquí
que yo sé que es 2 tiene que ser igual a
r por el seno de teta todo está siendo
escalado por una magnitud de r por un
factor de r
r siendo de teta muy bien entonces cómo
puedo a partir de estos valores obtener
reconocen a beteta cuanto vale por
ejemplo theta empecemos contenta pues
recordemos recordemos que la tangente de
teta
una tangente del ángulo theta es igual
el valor del seno de teta
se nota
/ el co seno de eta
/ y cosenos de teta pero yo puedo
multiplicar por r el número el numerador
y el denominador sin cambiar el valor de
esta expresión así que esto es lo mismo
que eres en 9 t está dividido en 3
reconoce no detecta pero cuánto es eso
pues yo sé que eres enoé teta válidos
vale 2 y también sé que es reconocerlo
de teta vale menos 3
al menos 3 de modo que la tangente de
este ángulo de este ángulo theta tiene
que ser igual a 2 / menos 3 o lo que es
lo mismo a menos dos tercios otro modo
de interpretar este resultado es como la
pendiente de esta línea de la línea
celeste porque cuál sería la pendiente
pues mi avance mi desplazamiento en
la dirección x de este punto hacia acá
es de 3 positivo y me alza en realidad
no es un alza sino es un descenso de
menos dos así que tendría que la
pendiente de esta recta la recta celeste
es menos dos tercios de modo que si yo
quiero obtener theta un partido de esta
ecuación theta va a ser igual a la
tangente inversa la tangente inversa de
menos dos tercios ahora sí voy a sacarme
calculadora y veamos cuál es la tangente
a antes que nada hay que checar que esté
en radiales
si estoy en radiales así que ok
y ahora sí cuál es la tangente inversa d
- 2
tercios
y me dice que es menos 5.88 vamos a
decir menos 0.59 esto es aproximadamente
menos 0.59 ahora eso tiene sentido pues
este ángulo este ángulo corresponde a un
ángulo que estaría en este cuadrante a
este ángulo de aquí que es simplemente
el ángulo que sería deformado por la
continuación de este rayo así que en
realidad este no es el ángulo que
queremos tiene sentido que la
calculadora nos haya dado este este
ángulo porque este rayo tiene la misma
pendiente que este rayo pero nosotros
queremos este ángulo que está está
a media vuelta
de el rayo que tenemos así que en
realidad lo que tenemos que hacer es
sumar irradian es el ángulo que nos dio
la calculadora la teta que realmente
queremos teta va a ser igual a como más
bien aproximadamente igual a menos 0.59
más bien
y eso cuánto es
eso es
que vamos a poner fin
más ping en 2.55 3 vamos a decir 2.55
2.55 ahora eso tiene sentido pues veamos
si parto de aquí del origen el eje
imaginario esta api medios radiales y
pies 3.14 vamos a pensar así que pi
medios es como 1.57 y esto sería piqué
3.14 15 92 etcétera entonces este número
efectivamente está entre estos dos
valores y por lo tanto si tiene sentido
que este ángulo este ángulo y en
radiales sea
valor de teta ahora que hay ver cuánto
va a leer pues para averiguar cuánto
vale r podemos usar simplemente el
teorema de pitágoras vamos a dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo
aquí
simplemente voy a dejar caer esto y aquí
se me forma un triángulo rectángulo este
lado esta altura mide 2 x que es igual a
esta altura 2 y este lado mide 3 a pesar
de que la coordenada es menos 3 la
longitud de este lado es 3 ahora yo sé
que entonces r al cuadrado
r va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de 2
al cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado
qué cuánto es 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 al
cuadrado es 9 así que r vale raíz de 13
bien y con esta información podemos
reescribir a zeta ceta va a ser igual a
ya no voy a escribir menos 3 sino que lo
voy a sustituir por r coseno eta donde r
es esta magnitud y vale raíz de 13 y
theta es esta dirección y vale 2.55
radiales entonces z va a ser igual a ere
coseno beteta que es lo mismo que raíz
de 13 país de 13 por el coche no de 2.55
radian es de 2.55
+ 2
todos pero dos es igual a r s no de 30
que es lo mismo que raíz de 13
raíz de 13 por el seno de 2.55 radiales
por i
por e incluso si quiero puedo puedo
limpiar un poco este desorden y puedo
hacer explícito que z es igual a el
radio el radio que es raíz de 13
13 13 radio la magnitud del mundo x
el coseno
vamos a escribirlo con colores
el radio es raíz de 13
13 x
el consuelo de 2.55 radiales
más veces
más veces el seno de 2.55 radiales y de
este modo de este modo es bastante claro
que para llegar a zeta
tengo que primero ir en ubicar la
dirección de 2.55 radiales que es esta
de aquí y luego alejarme una distancia
de raíz de 13 del origen esta instancia
de aquí y por eso cuando escribo un
número complejo z en esta forma se llama
la forma rectangular y cuando lo hago de
esta manera se llama la forma polar